all right before we dive into this
episode the minimalist want to help you
declutter your glowing screen so head on
over to the minimalists comm slash
wallpapers to download any of our free
minimalist wallpapers including our love
people use things wallpaper for your
smartphone or computer enjoy hello
everybody welcome to the minimalist
podcast where we discuss what it means
to live a meaningful life with less my
name is Joshua fields Millburn and I'm
Ryan Nicodemus and together we are the
minimalist today we're gonna talk about
buying new and used material possessions
with intention we're gonna talk about
purchasing products that last a lifetime
and we're gonna talk about being
responsible with our time and money when
we shop for the things we need and we're
gonna do all of that with today's guest
Tara button is here she's a founder of
buy me one stock comp she's also the
author of a life less throw away if
you're watching on YouTube I'll hold up
her book here you can check that out
we'll put a link to both of those in the
show notes as well Tara thank you for
joining us thanks for being here we've
had the scheduled for I think couple
months now I've really been looking
forward to this because we share very
similar philosophies we're gonna be
talking about your website Bobby wants
calm we're also gonna be answering some
questions and I thought the best place
to start today was with Gina's question
she's from Minneapolis hey guys this is
Gina from Minnesota and I just started
listening to your podcast and I'm
starting my downsizing and I'm running
into a small problem as I'm trying to
perfect the capsule wardrobe and kind of
carrying on my item I find that as I get
rid of items aren't certain I catch
myself shopping more and more to find
like one perfect replacement for example
getting rid of 10 low quality flutters
and then setting out to find the one
perfect one and I feel like it's really
counterintuitive in that even on the
Tron trying to be down but I'm finding
myself feeding into consumerism and I
was just wondering if you had any tips
for it a practice of downsizing and
mental minimalism but just being
satisfied with what you have instead of
seeking out and feeding into your
two more of them Gina I have good news
for you it's okay that you still want to
go shopping every once in a while I mean
I am one of the minimalists and I still
desire to have stuff but you know what I
would say like I actually enjoy shopping
more now than what I did in the past
really I'm the exact office well for me
it's because I am I'm more deliberate
with it so like right now Mariah and I
were it's like our car has to be
replaced eventually in kind of going
through the experience of trying to find
a good deal trying to find the car it's
something that that I don't hate doing I
mean it's it's still when when you got
your blackberry I mean weren't you like
oh man I got my black bear and you were
excited you had the keyboard back yeah
you did you did an unboxing video I
learned a lesson about that in a way
that lay-oh
being excited about new products for me
is actually a problem now Terry you you
your website is really about about the
intentional bringing things into our
lives intentionally but also things that
last a long time
and I think that's what Gina is looking
at right now she's saying hey look I'm
I'm I'm decluttering I'm downsizing I'm
getting rid of this excess stuff that
isn't really appropriate for my life
anymore
but the problem having is now all the
sudden I just want to consume new things
that I think are appropriate right now
I'm sure you run across this all the
time absolutely and I think it's
important to mention that you know when
you are downsizing that doesn't mean
getting rid of everything you own I what
I suggest doing in this case is to look
at the products that you do own and try
and find you're kind of you're 18
products and also try and figure out
what it is about those products that you
do own the IOA team and when I say
you're a team it's like when everything
is washed what do you reach for fast
what is like that thing that you know
there's going to make you feel great and
and then try and figure out what it is
about that product that's so good and
then when you do come to buy a new item
then go for something that kind of
matches that so what we say it by me
once is don't buy anything you don't
need if you do need something buy for
the long term because it's
best thing you can do for the
environment to save money but also for
your mental health because it means they
are not constantly having to replace
shoddy items in your life yeah what I
love about what you do Tara is that you
help people with consumerism because
consumerism is still a necessary thing
we all have to consume some things now
Gina right yeah Gina when I was shopping
and you know my years of yesteryear when
I go I would go out and just browse Best
Buy like every time I got a big
Commission check I would just literally
go to Best Buy and walk around and get
cassette tapes no no no I actually would
not buy cassette tapes or CDs but but
the thing is is that when I did that I
was there was this void I was trying to
fill there was something much deeper
going on and my guests Gina is that
there is something deeper going on with
with this urge to consume so what I
would recommend is find something else
that fulfills you but is meaningful
something that aligns with your values
and beliefs get clear on what those are
first and then start making decisions on
how you can you know fill those buckets
so to speak so if you've got five
different values look at how full each
value is in your life look at those as
you know kind of buckets of sand and if
one of those is empty if you try to fill
that bucket that's gonna be much more
meaningful than going out and buying a
new shirt but she's doing the tenon or
I'm sorry don't do that
she's doing the one in ten out rule
which is a great rule I mean she's
getting rid of ten things she's getting
one thing but you know I think it's okay
as long as you're not doing it that what
you're not doing you don't want to do
well I need to get rid of ten things and
then as a reward I'm going to buy one
thing I think it's it's generally the
opposite like I don't think she said it
as a reward though you know she said she
was doing it to replace the ten things
she got rid of she got rid of ten
sweaters all right so now she wants to
get the one sweater I got rid of ten
pairs of jeans and now I have one pair
of pants and I really enjoy those pants
I wear though it's the only pair of
jeans that I have right I like them when
I put them on I feel good about myself
I'm very very satisfied with that
purchase
now usually with my clothes I go to you
to help me shop because that I don't
enjoy because I just don't have much
style well here's the thing I with the
the the the one in 10 out rule that the
point is like if I'm going to bring
something in and I have an overabundance
of stuff I'm going to force myself to
either not bring it in because I don't
can't don't have anything I can get rid
of or if I'm good if I have to bring
that thing in then I'm going to try to
get rid of ten things now that's that's
predicated on the sort of one in one out
rule you but but Ryan and I were very
extreme at first when we went to
decluttering or there are there any
rules that help you with respect to to
being more conscious about your
consumption the thing that most helped
me and this is a little bit
counterintuitive I actually wrote a list
of things that I didn't need most people
write plenty of lists of things that
they want or they do need but writing
this list down actually just gave me an
appreciation of everything I already had
so that was super useful
what a great because it's an infinite
list theoretically but like as you start
listing all of these things we could
fill up this table and size six font of
things I don't need but also here's a
fascinating twist to that maybe it's
like things I once thought I needed but
now I know I don't need because we can
justify anything right and the thing the
types of things I didn't use like I do
not need anymore notebooks as a as a
writer and as someone who loves
creativity like the need or the feeling
that these notebooks are gonna suddenly
spark something incredible from my mind
is like ever president if I go into a
stationery store it's like right but
just having written it down and actually
committing to say I don't need these
things and in my home I now have all of
my notebooks all in a row and these are
unused notebooks so that all kind of
laid out like they would be in a store
so I have my own stationery store kind
of in my house ready to go of all the
notebooks that over the years I've
managed to collect so now I always think
back to that and I go I definitely don't
need it and that gives me the strength
to pass them on by yeah I love that Gina
I'm gonna send you two books one is
Tara's book
a life less throw away we're gonna send
you a copy of that and also our book
essential it's an essay collection of
150 different essays about intentional
living there are two chapters in there
that I think you'll find particularly
useful one is about stuff the other is
about minimalism their essays on both of
those topics plus ten other areas of
intentional living if you like our
podcast you will like the audiobook
version of that or if you want the book
book or the eBook version we're happy to
send those to you as well our next
question is from Elizabeth in Copenhagen
hi I'm 17 years old I live in Denmark
and my question is like I've started on
this animal attorney I really think I've
come a long way and I do the
decluttering in like have the whole
mindful gel with you but I feel like go
for the time like I keep coming back to
the consumerism part I keep on like
buying a lot and more and like keep on
shopping but the minimalism ideally it's
always in my head and it always makes a
penny and it seems so right and but it
just keep on coming back to the
consumerism so how can I stop shopping
now Tara I've been working on an essay
about this it's called step zero and
it's do nothing mmm like I think that's
one thing we often forget about as we're
like getting really good on this journey
like I get excited about minimalism or
you get excited about shopping all of a
sudden it's like boom I need to go buy
this thing or I need to go declutter
this thing but for me step zero is do
nothing it's to respect the sort of
pause there's a moment of like okay like
I want to go consume this thing I want
to go buy this I want to go shopping I
want to go to the mall I want to bring
this into my life I want to do this I
need these things to be happy but before
I go out and do that maybe step 0 is do
nothing and and that's the first thing
I'm going to talk to Elizabeth about
here is you're actually asking some
really important questions you're 17
years old and you're asking how can I
consume more deliberately this whole
minimalism thing makes sense to me
Wow I mean
to you for recognizing this right now
and not waiting until you're 27 37 47 57
we've had people in their 80s come to
our Vince decluttering for the first
time in my life and well that's great
you're recognizing it at the beginning
of your life the beginning of your
adulthood now Ryan touched on something
earlier where he said your consumption
is necessary but consumerism is is not
you know consumerism is is unintentional
but we all need to consume some things
and so these questions you're asking
yourself right now or what are the
things that are appropriate for this
stage in my life now there are some
things that you'll buy that will last
you a generation or maybe even a
lifetime and I think that's the thing
with with by me once is it's not like
you're gonna buy this and you have to
keep it for the rest of your life but if
you want a couch for example maybe that
couch is gonna last you decades as
opposed to something that will crumble
after six months of of sitting on it and
actually having something that lasts a
really long time means that it holds its
value so much better so that if you did
want to pass it on either to your kids
or to sell it then it means that it
holds that value first for so much
longer but what I would like to say to
Elizabeth that it really means firstly
it's incredibly impressive that you're
getting involved with this stuff but
secondly it really doesn't surprise me
that she's struggling and that's because
every message apart from maybe this
podcast and a couple of websites is the
opposite it is to buy and as somebody
who worked in advertising for 10 years I
know how manipulative it is and how it
it's incredibly hard because you can
consciously want to live them in a most
lifestyle but advertising doesn't work
on that level advertising works directly
to our subconscious and I know this
because I've written them to be as
manipulative as possible and I'm now
kind of paying my penance for that by by
starting by me once and writing this
book but and being conscious of this
manipulation and the way that it gets
into our heads is one of the first steps
there
I would say yeah no I love that like
when I think about when I first went
down the minimalism road that my
minimalism journey I realized how the
magazine's I got the TV shows I watched
like there were these advertisements
that were seeping into my brain and I
wasn't even realizing how they were
affecting my my impulses winning when it
comes to consuming so never even thought
about yeah I am
the Rolex ad on the back of the the
magazine but the truth is like okay the
Rolex isn't going to buy you more time
right and and the Mercedes been
advertisement on you know the details
magazine or whatever you were subscribed
to at the time it's like oh yeah that's
gonna get me there faster no it's not
it's just going to get me into debt
faster they don't ever advertise the
debt that you're actually going to go
into how could you imagine you're gonna
have to work you know 2,000 hours in
order to pay off this your car and it's
like what wait a minute why am I doing
this it's actually it's extracting my
freedom for my life even though those
advertisements what do they portray they
portray a new kind of freedom now if you
just buy this you'll be more complete or
more happy or more adventurous you'll be
a different person if you buy this but
of course you won't be a different
person you'll just have more debt more
stress more discontent yeah so Elizabeth
I mean you could totally cut out some of
the advertisements in your life that'll
help a little bit but you know
ultimately for me like I said with
Gina's question like I still want to buy
stuff I wish I could sit here and say
listen to our podcast buy all our books
read everything on our website and
you'll never want to buy anything again
if anyone ever actually figures out that
formula let us know we'd love to know
because I still want to buy stuff
minimalism is not this there's not an
end game to it it's not it's not this
thing you get to and then now you can
live a perfect life minimalism is a
journey and it's constantly changing
because Elizabeth you're 17 years old
you're 70 year old self needs different
things than what your twenty
seven-year-old self is going to need and
minimalism will help you make those
decisions so the questions that she's
asking like like you said this is it's
really awesome that she's doing this at
17 years old she's 10 years Adam
in fact like any time a high schooler
reaches out to us it's one of the
biggest compliments like I love that
young people are already kind of in this
mindset avoiding debt worried about the
environment for whatever reason they are
in into our message it's it's really
really really it's inspiring to me so
thank you for inspiring me Elizabeth one
thing I'll say too is you know what I do
men when I feel like I want to I feel
empty I don't go to shopping so that is
one thing I'll say that I have totally
changed when I feel empty I don't go to
Best Buy that doesn't even pop into my
head but what I will do is I will find a
way where I can give and that might be
like calling my mom that might be going
to the soup kitchen it might be walking
down the street and there's a homeless
dude who's like I need five bucks for me
I'll go buy him a chicken sandwich or
something
like going out of my way on Popeyes or
chick-fil-a well since Popeyes doesn't
have any chicken sandwiches ever they
continuously run out on bread did you
hear that get out of here you can bring
your own bun that's what they do you
know this is a marketing ploy right oh
it's hot out of chicken sandwich and
there gee they're geniuses for making
this but yeah I mean I mean go out of
your way to contribute because there are
things that you can do impulsively that
actually do add value not just to other
people's lives but to your own life and
if you can find those solutions like
that is how you're going to be the
happiest Elizabeth but you know again
you're always going to have that that
impulse to to buy I mean living I'm Josh
and I writing this book right now and I
was reading the chapter on stuff and you
mentioned in that chapter about how
we're in the land of like Lamborghinis
and Tesla's and Rodeo Drive and in it's
fixable decker strip malls yeah so
living in LA like we are in the thick of
consumerism and every time I see a Tesla
like oh I want a Tesla and every time I
see a nice suit I'm like you know what I
think I might go and get a nice suit I
mean there are all these impulses that I
have but because I have instilled this
philosophy and these values into my life
it's much easier for me to stave off
those impulses so Elizabeth you're doing
the right things you're 17 years old
not to mention being in high school and
like all her friends
and you know I think that the one things
that young people and what any people
can do is really take the time to take a
step back get to know yourself your
actual tastes and what you care about
because you're getting messages from
everywhere about what you should care
about but actually doing the research on
yourself in advance means that when you
do go to a shop and you do feel like you
want to buy something at least we'll be
right buying something that you might
like for the long term or at least a few
years rather than something that is an
impulse purchase which is then sits in
your closet and that's where we end up
with so many clothes nothing to wear
feeling and and so I don't think
Elizabeth should beat herself up for
wanting to buy things at all I think you
know purchase mindfully and you know
that will be it and way out yeah
Elizabeth I'm gonna give you two
concrete things to to consider here one
we call it the wait for it roll or the
30-30 rule and basically to stave off
impulse I can afford something that
costs $15 or or $40 right now let's say
I go on Amazon I want to buy this widget
that's $40 I can afford that right now
but if anything is over $30 I wait 30
hours to buy it and if it's over a
hundred bucks I try to wait 30 days and
so we call that the wait for a rule or
the 30-30 rule it's easier to remember
with 30 30 there's also the 10 most
expensive possessions rule and and it
really it's a theory from Geoffrey
Miller who wrote a book called spent and
what you do is you take a piece of paper
you write a line down the middle and I'm
doing this here on camera but you're
write a line down the middle and on one
side you write down the 10 most
expensive possessions that you own or
that you want to own and then you write
down the 10 most memorable experiences
of the the the 10 most the the 10 things
that bring you the most joy what's
called 10 joy so 10 possessions and 10
joy
and you'll be shocked that probably zero
things on these two lists overlap and
when you do that it gives you some power
to realize like oh like the tool the
things in my life are tools in my life
and they can augment my life they can
help out but the core message of
minimalism is probably this you probably
don't need that and if you think about
it that way then you can bring anything
things to your life that will help
enhance your life but they won't get in
the way of the joy that you're trying to
purchase by buying those things
Elizabeth I'm gonna send you a copy of
our book minimalism live a meaningful
life in that book you're asking about
how do we what do I fill my life with if
it's not consumerism well Ryan alluded
to this earlier with values you have to
get clear on what your values are and
that book is really about identifying
your foundational values and how they
apply to your life the five foundational
values so I think you'll enjoy that in
the audio book the book book or the
eBook version of minimalism live a
meaningful life Ryan what time is it you
know what time it is it is time for our
lightning round where we answer
questions from social media indeed we do
we are at the minimalists on Facebook
Twitter and Instagram Terra I think
you're just at terra button and at by me
once okay beautiful so you can you can
tweet her Instagram her snapchat her
myspace or whatever the the kids are
doing these days and what we'll put a
link to her social media and her website
in the show notes as well Ryan what's
the first question here from man oh man
oh man oh right sin how do I know what I
really want is what I really need mmm
that's a great question
yes so so one in need I mean I actually
just touched on this a little bit you
probably don't need that is the the core
message of minimalism I think most of
the things in our lives we don't need in
the the truest sense of the word need
like I need shelter I need food I need I
guess I need clothing because it's
illegal not to wear it right but but
most of the things are once and it's
okay to want some stuff right Tara all
right to want some stuff but the trouble
with consumers and materialism is that
it really does get in the way of a
happiness there's been incredible
studies which shows that when we feel
the consumers we change our attitude to
life in in general so I think it's about
really thinking about what what we lose
when we focus on on consuming and what
we want and actually give us the impetus
to really answer this question what do
we need and and what do we want and and
I think actually writing that list of
things that you don't need is a good
place to start because you'll see all
the things that you have in general and
I think that what we all need is
connection above everything every study
that I read in order to research this
book just brought it back to people and
what your community is like and what
your relationships are like and I think
that if your needs are being met on an
emotional level with your relationships
that's when you realize that there's so
little material things that you actually
need yeah yeah and those things that we
bring in if they're actually getting in
a way of that connection if they're
getting in the way of community now
there are a bunch of ways that things
can get in the way right it can mean
well and I have to work more hours in
order to pay this off so I'm not
spending time with my significant other
with my friends or I'm not contributing
to the community or they might get in
the way of well you don't have enough
time to focus on your health or they
might get your consumption might get in
the way of your creating and so there
are a bunch of ways that things get in
the way of course the most obvious one
is physically right if the average
American household has 300,000 items in
it were we're literally tripping over
our things they get in the way that way
but then there are so many other ways
that they sort of get in the way
figuratively now with the lightning
round we try to do is sum it up with a
short pithy less than 140 character
response I'm I'm sure Tara said a few
things there about connection that
podcast Shawn can tweeze out there and
make a tweetable version for the the
show notes well my
my pithy answer to this is sometimes
everything you ever wanted isn't
actually what you want and it's only
about 30 years to figure that out I
thought like happiness was right around
the bend it was one purchase away and if
I got that Lexus then I would be happy
and then when I wasn't I kid you not if
I got the second Lexus then I'll be
happy and of course we called this the
the hedonic treadmill and we continue to
acquire thinking the things are going to
bring us happiness but happiness is
never is never brought to us by these
externalities pleasure can be you know
temporary ephemeral pleasure but it's
always fleeting and in in the the drug
world that they call that chasing the
dragon right you get you get high and
you're like oh I need to return to that
again well we get high from consumerism
and we try to return to that but of
course it never works it doesn't bring
us that contentment
we're actually searching for yeah
definitely Tara I think you've got a
better answer than me and you what what
you said really stands out to me is
there's one thing we all need for sure
and that is connection like that's that
is absolutely true
I picked the answer Josh what you were
talking about earlier it was a perfect
segue to it it's okay to have something
you want as long as you can afford the
real cost so it's more than money like
money is the initial barrier but there's
so many other costs storing the thing
repairing the thing the space you need
for the thing it's like when I when I
think about things that I want like I
really when I was in Montana I really
wanted to like do fly fishing because
that is like the most cliche thing you
can do in Montana but I was I could very
easily talk myself out of it yes I could
afford it monetarily yeah I probably had
the space to keep you know my fishing
pole and and the tackle that goes along
with it but ultimately I did not have
the time to add another hobby to my life
if I did bring that into my life I knew
I was gonna have to give up mountain
biking or snowboarding or longboarding
or you know anything else that you can
do on a board and I wasn't willing to
give this things up for fly-fishing I
love
there's a pithy answer in there you
don't have the time to own more yeah
that's good man and and when you think
about about that it's like we don't ever
consider the time our most precious
resource that and attention that the
that's a cost the cost about worrying
over the thing and then in fretting and
and and the psychological weight and
psychological cost of all these things
that is such a good example of our
relationship you've got all the good
words man yeah of course it is that no
item can make you more or less of a
person yeah
it's absolutely true it's absolutely
true I mean if you can't with any of
these questions like if you cannot look
in the mirror and be happy with yourself
right now there is no there is no you
know materialistic thing you can buy
that's going to make you like yourself
more you know if you're starving you're
starving you need food if you're thirsty
if you're dehydrated you need water but
besides you know those those life
essentials there's nothing that you
bring in your life that's gonna make you
feel more complete alright before we
dive into our added value segment and
our listener tips and tricks it looks
like we have a bunch more surprise
questions today including what's the
best way to replace my sunglasses if I
always lose them get rid of your eyes
that's easy wait a minute can I spend
money on clothing if I'm still in debt
how can I spend less money on
high-quality food how do you avoid
analysis paralysis when making
purchasing decisions what are the key
questions to ask yourself when
delineating want versus need and we have
so much more to talk about with Tara
button and if you want to hear all that
you can listen to this week's maximal
episode available exclusively on patreon
that's right you're currently listening
to our weekly minimal episode but each
week Ryan and I record an entirely
different much much longer maximal
episode on the minimalists private
podcast which gives us the private space
we need to talk about topics we don't
usually discuss in public Plus patreon
is the best way for us to fund this
podcast keep it 100%
advertisement free when you subscribe to
the minimalist private podcast on
patreon you'll also receive a personal
link so that our maximum episodes play
in your favorite podcast app find all
the details and all the good stuff
including an additional private podcast
episode every week over at the
minimalists comm slash support it's also
worth noting Ryan we were over 4,000
patrons now which is amazing which also
means that Sean podcast Sean Jordan no
more and social Jess are going to do a
podcast episode together just for the
patrons excited and we're capping our
audience at 6,000 patrons as well so
we're more than two-thirds of the way
there if you're interested in becoming a
supporter of the podcast and getting all
of the private podcasts we want to keep
that audience relatively small at six
thousand people now is the time you can
find that over at the minimalists comm
slash support Ryan what else you got for
us read more and get informed you can do
that by checking out Tara buttons book a
life less throw away and also I got some
voicemail comments and tips from our
listeners check them out hi my name is
Kathleen and I'm from Nashville
Tennessee I'm calling to respond to
episode 52 on stress I have two tips for
Tasha the teacher I am also a teacher a
teacher writing class for eleventh and
twelfth graders and grading papers is
always very time-consuming I'm not
convinced that there's a way around that
even though I've been trying for years
now I have discovered that with writing
my students learn a lot more when they
edit and correct their work so I'd like
to suggest that Tasha have students
grade their own papers you shouldn't do
this with every paper but you can easily
set up a system where students grade
their own papers every now and then you
can write a worksheet that asks them to
identify key parts of their paper like
topic sentences and supporting points in
conclusion sentences and grade their own
work you can customize your worksheet to
fit whatever concepts are covering at
that part of the school year and you can
also have students trade with each other
and grade each other's papers both
options require some setup and structure
put in place first but it's a wonderful
way to help students learn what
makes their making in their writing
without having you just tell them what
they're doing wrong second I heard this
on another podcast but I think it's a
great piece of advice your district
probably only requires a certain number
of grades per semester or per quarter
most teachers actually give out more
grades than they have to so look into
the requirements for your district and
district and talk to the administration
at your school about how many numerical
grades you need to give out and see if
what you're doing is more than is
required teaching can be really
rewarding work but it is a lot of work I
want to encourage Tasha to look up new
methods of teaching and talk to other
teachers about how they manage the
workload it can get better
hi my name's Cassidy I live in st. Pete
Florida I just listening to the podcast
about impulses and I was listening to
Erica talk about her small business and
how she get stressed out kind of over
other people's consumerism and I was
just thinking like you know for the
example she gave about the lady buying
more yarn when Sheri had so much it if
that's something that stresses her out
she can maybe try doing like workshops
or offer some sort of incentives I don't
know what else she sold but maybe have
some sort of event where people bring in
their old yarn and there's some sort of
class where she can educate or how to
utilize what people already have or
maybe use something like an incentive or
people come in bring their excess that
they're not using and that can be given
a discount towards the people purchasing
something else and then utilize that
those are items for maybe some sort of
events that help people in the community
whether it's a free event or something
for children or senior citizens
something where you can give back and
that way those materials are being used
again that aren't being used by the
people who already have them and then
people are also kind of reallocating
their resources that they're not
utilizing in their own home and thus
minimizing what they have in helping
others so that was just something when I
was listening to that that I thought
could be really helpful you know if
she's very passionate and love is her
business that she is going on so it's
not like I have to give up and try
something all new and start all over and
potentially have the same problems all
over again this might be a solution to
where it causes less stress for her for
Erica and her business and then she's
also kind of providing to her clientele
as well as her community all right y'all
thanks again to Tara button for joining
us today you can check her out by me
once dot-com you can also find her on
social media at Tara button real quick
four right here right now here's one
thing that's going on in the life of the
minimalists actually two things today
Ryan you just did your home tour a
beautiful beautiful home you have
and I was actually surprised by how
little you owned I mean I know you're a
minimalist and and you and I have been
best friends for a long time but it
seems to me that like when you
la you really you and Mariah asked that
question like how much is too much
and it turns out you don't need much to
actually be happy and so I would
encourage folks to check out his home
tour over at youtube.com slash the
minimalists and also on our website if
you you can find his home tour the
minimalists comm slash ryan you can find
it there and on our website right now if
you go to the minimalists comm slash
before the word before we have a free
wallpaper for your smartphone and for
your computer it's the five questions
you should ask yourself before buying
anything and I really like this because
it's a good reminder to have this on
your phone if you're like waiting in
line at you know wherever CVS or Target
or or
where do you shop these days Ryan
Charlotte Russe sure Fred Segal okay
because I like to I like to pretend I'm
you okay so we're at Fred Segal you're
like I really need these overalls or
whatever you're buying is that what the
kids are wearing and and you're waiting
in line and it's a wallpaper has I need
to ask these five questions it's a good
reminder you have it write down your
phone or you have in your computer if
you do an online shopping or you can
even print it out as the small like PDF
poster and post it like near your desk
so I'm where like I'm getting ready to
buy this thing
let me ask these five questions first
and if I feel good about after after
after I feel good about it after I ask
these five questions and answer them
then I can still buy the thing so it's a
free wallpaper for you for your phone
for your computer to print out if you'd
like the minimalists com a slash before
if you have a question comment or
minimalism tip for our podcast leave us
a voicemail for zero six two one nine
seven eight three nine or send a voice
memo to podcast at the minimalists comm
you can comment on this episode at
youtube.com slash the minimalists if you
want our show notes in your inbox sign
up for our email list at the top of the
minimalists comm you also get our simple
Sunday emails for our added value this
week let's listen to a song from the
Lumineers new album if you heard this
album yet Ryan no it's really good it's
about it's about addiction so you and I
can definitely relate to it just growing
up in families that have both struggled
with addiction and it's a three part
album
so it's actually four parts because they
have like three bonus songs so it's four
disks and we don't listen to discs
anymore but three songs each and so it's
about an individual and then shifts
perspective and it's I struggling with
addiction and and sort of all the
baggage and the weight and the turmoil
within your family that comes along with
that and it's a beautiful album it's
it's very it's very minimalist very
stripped down the instrumentation is
gorgeous and that's all I'd like to
close the cell with today from that
album by the way the album is called
three just the Roman Roman numeral three
the song I'd like to close the show with
today is salt and the sea and if you
leave here today with just one message
we hope what's this love people and use
things because the opposite never works
thanks for listening yeah we'll see you
next time minimus